نتحدث عن الوضع في اصلاحيه سالتقي احد
الاشخاص من اللاجئين السوريين الذي كان
هنا في اصلاحيه وفقد عددا من افراد عائلته
ساتعرف عليه بدايه
اسف مصطفى خطيب
من محافظه ادلب
من عشر سنوات
بوقت الزلزال لما صار الزلزال انت كنت
بالبيت كنت برا البيت خارج البيت انا
وابني اسمعني هزه الارضيه وصلنا في اتجاه
البيت
طلعنا البيت
والعين باماكن كثيره
يقولوا البنايه فيها
الام وبنات
عائلتي
ورحنا طلعنا خطرنا نسمع صوت من بعيد تقول
انه ماده التاني والتالته
وظلت بنت طيبه والام
م
الله يرحمه
في اربع خمس ساعات انا طالعتهم انا وابني
وابن اخته
ما في عمليه طوارئ ما حدا ساعدكم انتم لا
توقف نحكي كذا ما ترد علينا
وبعد ما طلعناهم ضلوا على الرصيف ست ساعات
وكمان جينا نشيلهم باسعاف او بطبيعه
الطوارئ ما يوقفوا سياره مدنيه شو السبب
يعني كان في ضغط ولا هو ضغط فيه بس يعني
في ناس موته مبينه يعني
وخلصنا بس وصلنا على المشفى
بعد ست ساعات شو عملتوا نقلت
وعنده
والجرحى والمراه والبنت بالمشفى عنتاب صار
له من يوم الزلزله هلا يعني اركب لعندي نص
اللي عندي شو صار فيه ما بيجيكم مساعدات
انت وين
اما المواطن التركي له امور ومحلوله
شيء
ولا سوريا
طيب حضرتك هلا وين مقيم مقيم مع الرصيف
وبالشوارع وين في قرن فاضي بنعم فيها
نتمنى اول شيء الله يرحم بناتك نتمنى
الشفاء لزوجتك ولبنتك اللي بالمشفى كمان
نتمنى لك انه تنتهي هاي المحنه وما بنتمنى
لاي حدا تصيبه هاي المحنه الصعبه حقيقه
يعني هي معاناه كتير من العائلات السوريه
اللي التقيناهم هون في اصلاحيه او في
نورداق بعض العائلات تم توفير
خيام لالون لكن مع الاسف مو كل العائلات
تم توفير القيام او حتى كل المساعدات شكرا
لك جزيلا كما تابعنا يعني هذه حاله من
حالات كثيره فقدت
فقدوا احباء وفقدوا اصدقاء وفقدوا ابناء
مع الاسف يعني حجم المعاناه ما زال كبيرا
واثار الزلزال الان بدانا بمعاينه الحالات
الانسانيه الصعبه بدات غبار البحث
والانقاذ وعمليات البحث وانقاذ الغبار
المتصاعد بدا ينجلي وبدانا نكتشف تباعا
هول هذه الكارثه